c'est un policier qui a été mis en
examen c'est pas tous les policiers qui
ont été mis en examen
alors est-ce qu'un policier peut
commettre des erreurs oui bien sûr
est-ce qu'il y a à améliorer la
formation sans aucun doute d'ailleurs
nous avons proposé 4 fois plus la
proposition est plus vous l'avez voté je
vous en remercie faut-il faire davantage
sans doute sans doute faut-il mieux
sélectionner les policiers très
certainement je constate avec vous si
vous me le permettez que je suis à la
tête d'un ministère ou à part les
commissaires de police ce que nous
recrutons c'est souvent des enfants pour
reprendre notre mot de 18 de 19 de 20
ans qui n'ont pas fait de très grandes
études et qui choisissent ce service de
la nation par la police gendarmerie je
ne suis pas la tête du Sada justice où
les gens passent des concours avec +4
bac + 5 ou éducation nationale aux gens
sont très mal payés par ailleurs comme
les policiers enfin ils ont un capital
social très important
mettons-nous quelques instants à la
place d'un majorité majorité de jeunes
qui choisissent ce service de la police
et de gendarmerie que nous devons former
nous
ça demande une exigence supplémentaire
parce qu'en plus ces personnes ont la
contrainte légitime des armes et donc
par ailleurs une responsabilité
supplémentaire et à nous savoir pourquoi
et pour quelle raison ils veulent
rentrer dans la police gendarmerie c'est
la première question que je pose à des
policiers à des gendarmes quand je les
croise dans l'école
on est tous toujours très touchés par
exemple nos témoignages et il y a
parfois des questions qu'on peut se
poser donc 1 je veux dire que oui on
doit améliorer sans cesse et ce sera un
travail jamais terminé le travail des
policiers et des gendarmes sans aucun
doute je suis le premier à ne pas
accepter à son instant qu'on tutoie les
personnes
c'est inacceptable qu'on est 15 ans
qu'on soit étranger en situation
irrégulière ou qu'on soit présent
directeur général d'une société on ne
peut pas tutoyer les personnes alors
évidemment c'est plus facile à dire dans
les fauteuils du Sénat sur le terrain
mais c'est la hauteur de la Prestation
nationale nous ne sommes pas une bande
rivale contre une autre grande rivale
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça monsieur Durand
et vous le savez que j'ai pris à sa
tombe de décision lorsque j'ai vu des
policiers manifestés en cagoule on n'est
pas une bande rivale contre une autre
grande rivale c'est pas ça la République
donc oui il faut sans cesse améliorer un
travail difficile de formation des
policiers oui vous avez raison Madame la
Gontrie trois tyran administratifs c'est
pas assez notamment les tirs dit en
mouvement parce que c'est ça la
difficulté quand je suis arrivé au
ministère de la table à la gaubrerie 60%
des policiers seulement vers leurs trois
tirs administratifs c'est leur
administration qui est responsable de
leur sécurité et la première chose que
fait l'igpet de l'iggène c'est de
vérifier que le policier a fait trois
tirs administratifs et s'il n'a pas fait
il le sanctionne mais c'est pas lui qui
refuse de faire toiture administratif
c'est qu'il y a pas assez de stands de
tir c'est qu'il y a pas assez de temps
pour la formation c'est nous les
employeurs de ces policiers qui savent
responsables vous avez raison il faut
largement améliorer ça je crois que la
loi que vous avez votée nous permet de
le faire